[Music]
but I think the one thing Evan that
we're always focusing on is performance
not outcomes what are you doing to help
people help themselves when we say
things out loud
they're almost ten times more powerful
than when you think them evident all
right well ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to the model in the master show
where I bring on experts whose brain I
want to pick and learn from and
hopefully through my learning you guys
learn as well special guest here today
Trevor Malad he is a sports psychologist
he has been called the world's best
brain trainer and he's got a new book
coming out called it takes what it takes
and I'm excited to get my hands on
Trevor
welcome aboard man well I have a great
to be here excited to be here today love
what I just listened to and hope I can
carry my weight I love it now now take
us around where are you give us a little
tour so I am in Manhattan Beach
California right now right between
Manhattan and North Manhattan Beach
so really can I just sit outside and
talk mmm so I figured I I would just sit
outside and give everybody a little bit
of a view I love it man is that is that
home base for you this is home base
right now I kind of go between here and
my offices or in Scottsdale but yeah so
so excited
been on the road like 21 or 23 days so
we've got a little bit of a goofy voice
but I'll do the do the best normally I
don't sound like a mafioso but I'll do
my best I got in at about 2:00 last
night from from New York so or st. Louis
so but I'm excited to be here
cool Thank You Man well it takes what it
takes new book that that's coming out
I'm pumped to get my hands on it talk to
me about I know you're the mindset guy
and you focus so much on athletes how
does that parse over into the world of
entrepreneurship and business well I
think for me the because of the I guess
consumer facing nature of the sports
world I probably get a lot more of my
recognition through athletes in
particularly a five-foot
it's quarterback from Seattle and then
then a coach out of Tuscaloosa Alabama
which I was you know spent my time with
eight nine years but the truth is I've
been really it's about performance so
whether it's venture capital or whether
it's big business or whether it's
Goldman Sachs or whether it's special
operations or education or you know
coaches whatever it is yesterday I had a
thousand coaches from USA Swimming
really anybody that wants to get better
for the most part do similar things and
it starts with this great comment from
Joe Maddon who coach the Cubs you know
how do we learn how to do simple better
and I think that success leaves Clues
the sports world is a great metaphor
it's a you know it's interesting Evan I
get asked all the time well you know how
to sports relate to business I mean it's
the ultimate even a based business and I
think that's where it relates to
entrepreneurship you are your own brand
and only the best get promoted the the
firing rates almost three out of ten
professional coaches every year only 25%
of NFL players make it to a fourth year
so you're dealing with the best of the
best of the best the industry that I
work in with in sports is not an
industry you know there are there are no
Tony Robbins in the sports world there's
a handful of us that have an opportunity
to sort of liaison work in this world
but it's it's in never an industry
that's really grown there's probably
five to six programs out of the 132
Division one college programs and a
handful of NFL and NBA teams but for the
most part psychology means a reactive
part
but I think in the hands of coaches like
Nick Saban or athletes like Russell
Russell Wilson or Kirby smarter or a
select group of people they believe that
the mind can be treated proactively and
you can make great players greater and
good players better and that's where
I've spent the majority of my time so to
answer your question I think how it
relates to entrepreneurship is the
social Darwinist ik element of it right
an entrepreneur only survives by
developing a unique value proposition a
great
product and finding a way to get the
best out of his people and enter the
market efficiently and effectively and
an athlete has to do that and they have
a limited market window when someone's
coming to you and they know they want to
play on a higher level do they can they
articulate the thing that's holding them
back or is that you pulling it out of
them well you know I think there's kind
of four levels that that my father sort
of educated me on when I was really
young I think when people in any walk of
life Evan you know some people kind of
start out at this level called
unconscious incompetence so they may
come to you and they don't even know
that they don't know they don't know
that they have a problem they don't know
if it's if it's a skill problem if it's
a mind problem if it's a physiological
problem then you sort of evolved to this
conscious incompetence which sounds
crazy but conscious incompetence is
essentially at least I know that there's
something that needs to get fixed and
it's such a it's such a pivotal stage to
get to that point now in the sports
world we watch a lot of film right so if
you were on the Seattle Seahawks and you
just played Cincinnati Bengals this
weekend on Monday you're gonna walk in
to tell the truth Monday and so whatever
you did good or bad you're gonna know
all right and it's sort of like an
earnings call every Monday all right and
and and so you're consciously
incompetent all right you know what I
need to get better at this does it mean
you're gonna do it Evan but the
diagnosis is there and you accept it
then you have I think a lot of people at
this third phase called unconscious
competence which means they are good
from time to time but can't really
articulate why and I get a lot of people
I would say at that level that have
aptitude talent that they've put
together some performances but they
don't really know how to articulate and
how to sustain it so really what we're
striving for it any great program is
conscious competence this is what I do
this is how I sleep this is how I
prepare this I warm up this is my CRM
software this is my pipeline these are
the people that I work with this is how
I executed my plan I may not always
succeed but I think the one thing Evan
that we're always focusing on is
performance not outcomes
I think performance typically tells the
truth outcomes
can be deceptive you can have a really
good quarter a really good semester or
two quarters a really good game and not
do things right and you can sometimes do
everything right and just get beat so if
your goal is performance what are the
things that allow me to succeed in the
long term you'll win using me as an
example so I've got our YouTube channels
where this video is ultimately going to
live we've got two million subscribers
300 million views
it's the biggest channel in the industry
I want to go from 2 million to 10
million at the rate that we're growing
it's not fast enough you know gaining a
thousand two thousand your subscribers a
day is awesome but but it's just gonna
take too long to get there every major
growth I've had in my business has come
from me experiencing a major growth
myself and then I take that to my
business I could if you if you said Evan
this is what you suck at I'll go fix it
I don't know what I suck at that I need
to get to the next step right yeah so I
think I mean that that's that's the
ultimate question right so so first of
all you know how do you define who can
you look to that blazed that path before
right and I think that you know I
remember hearing a story in 1918 that
they closed the Patent Office because
they thought everything that had been
invented had already been invented
so why do why do we need a patent things
you know so we're gonna be limited by
our own beliefs so I think you know how
do you get to 10 million I remember I
saw an interview Drake was doing and
when he was 18 years old he said you
wanted to make 25 million dollars by the
20 by the time he was 25 and he did it
and then after he did it he said you
want to make a turn in 50 million by the
time he was 29 well that's different
than a lot of musicians you have to make
different decisions if you want to make
25 million dollars instead of just one
song you got to go to abu dhabi and play
for a prince you've got to go it get
involved in acting you've got to get
involved in entrepreneurship you got to
get involved in all sorts of other
things so it's interesting because I
feel like I'm more of an incrementalist
you know I'm more of I don't mind if I
go from 2 million to 2.5 and from 2.5 to
you know or what
it is from 2 million to 2 million you
know and 10,000 and gradually work my
way and but I think it starts with the
big plan and then identifying what we do
every summer we spend about eight weeks
at the college football programs that
work with and we start with the
fundamentals of thinking how does the
mind work how do we process how do the
outside people influence us how do we
influence us okay where is the power
come from do we have a plan how
important is our plan versus other
people's plan for us and that's one of
the things I think is so challenging
about the mindset nature is as I you
know if I'm in a Hudson bookstore in st.
Louis Missouri
everything is mindfulness and yoga and
and meditation and that's hard you know
I think I think more of the success of
anybody who is a really good performer
is in the simplicity and I think it's
your talent that takes over in the
complicated so for you let me go back to
the Drake part you know if it is 10
million you know then there's gonna be
and nobody's got there yet
then you're gonna have to look for other
people who've gotten there in different
industries and and and and and try to
see if you can aggregate the marginal
gains that they've been able to do so is
that different segments of people is
that is that branching into different
elements of your topics is that
different types of people that you're
going to interview is that a different
external marketing strategy but your
answers aren't going to be in this
industry just like for me I don't have a
lot of answers that I can learn from the
sport psychology industry because there
isn't a sports psychology industry in
sports right you know and I believe that
wholeheartedly
I just I think you know I think in pro
sports you have an infinite supply of
talent so why waste money developing
them if somebody that can't do what they
need to do just go get somebody new so
who are you modeling what are you doing
to break out of your industry since
you're already the best well I would say
I don't know that I would be the best I
I feel like you know Sports Illustrated
when they were in when they were asked
specifically about that I think that I'm
the only one of those guys knew so that
kind of be like the best player a
badminton player in Manhattan Beach but
I'll take it because you know you're
still you're still good but the New York
Yankees director mental conditioning and
the Dallas Cowboys Chad bowling is my
best friend we talk every day so we're
constantly talking and challenging and
pushing ourselves I spent yesterday with
the CEO of MGM studios you know I travel
kind of all around I spend a lot of time
with Ben Sherwood the former president
of ABC News I mean I try to spend a lot
of time around really capable talented
people and then obviously when you when
you're you know spend a weekend around
Russell Wilson and Sierra Wilson and
those people you know attitudes are
contagious I can tell you Evan I've
learned a lot more from the people I've
been around and their greatness then you
know anything I've done particularly but
I do think the quest is how do we make
the information in and around our
psychological architecture more clear
and I think that's my goal because I was
raised my whole life in it and I think
that the bigger thing I've probably
learned over the years is that learning
how to be less negative is by far more
powerful than trying to force yourself
to become more positive I think less
negativity is going to be the win for
our country as opposed to trying to
create this anxiety by making ourselves
go to an area that doesn't feel
authentic so I mean I was living your
story and growing up your you know your
dad would play Zig Ziglar and all these
motivational speakers and not started to
get ingrained into you and you've been
applying that over the basically entire
career so if I look at someone like you
who even if you won't say you're the
best you're you're if you're not the
best you're among the best you're you're
at the top of your field there's always
a handful of one-to-five people you're
one of those five for you to move into
Instagram and blow up your Instagram
account that's been done it's easy you
can model people there's lots of people
you can connect with and copy their
success and do it for you to get better
in sports psychology what's the next
step like you're already in the top five
the pack forward is unclear there's
nobody who's my
ahead of you how do you keep getting
better well it was interesting a few
years ago I got a call from Maria
Shriver and you know in my mind I
thought it was Maria Sharapova who I
knew for years in Bradenton Florida who
was great tennis player and her agents a
great friend of mine and so I was a
little bit confused but ultimately I
went out to Brentwood California and I
sat down and I met with her and it was
really interesting she said you know you
were really hard to find at that time I
didn't have Instagram or any social
media because it's not really a
requirement in sports I've only really
been on Instagram for six weeks because
I think in the sports world once you're
in the building you don't you know it's
not about I'm this or I'm that and I've
made eight hundred million dollars so
follow my plan and and I have nothing
there's nothing wrong with that model in
and around what I'm learning and seeing
these uh sort of thought leaders and
influencers it's just not how it works
in sports the athletes don't care about
you it's how can you help them overcome
the realities of the their time and
volume in the sport but Maria would ask
me this interesting question she said
you know it's really hard to track you
down but you seem to be at the top of
the field in sports I run a program
called architects of change instead of
speaking to 150 athletes I think you
have a voice that needs to speak to 150
million people it was the first time I'd
ever heard anything like that I'd never
even been you know really around someone
maybe like Maria and and for the
audience she would be President
Kennedy's niece and Arnold
Schwarzenegger his former wife and then
in her own right Today Show and she's
done a ton of things unaccomplished and
that really started me down this
different path which is what I'm talking
to you Evan so I don't believe there's a
lot more to do in sports you know
because there's only so many teams you
know in truth I have been with a lot of
great college teams and some great NFL
teams and some great individual athletes
so I think in that at that level I've
been able to do a lot of cool things
there's certainly more I could do and
there's a lot more I can learn I think
the bigger task now that I feel is how
do we take the the ideas that we've
learned in the Southie
some conference in this in the sports
world that I believe are so much simpler
and and as Maria felt they're built for
everybody whereas so much of the mindset
area now is built for the elite you know
I need to read this book because this
person went to Harvard what does that
have to do with anything right like like
with like I mean it's great if they did
Harvard's a great school don't get me
wrong but what's the concept what are
they talking about how does it relate
and it's not about the education of the
person who's coming to you it's about
their experience and where they've been
and who they've helped and who they've
influenced so I think the goal that
Russell Wilson and I had in our own
entrepreneurship as the CEO of limitless
Minds is how do we get this out to
everybody how do we take this idea of
neutral thinking and get it out to
everybody how do we help people
recognize that their own language is the
most powerful limiting factor in their
life and that we always control what we
say and I think the last point I'd make
Evan is to help people understand maybe
what they don't do is the key to
changing their life it's not things that
they have to do but what they don't
watch what they don't say what they
don't listen to might be the key to
changing their lives as opposed to
trying to add all these things while
we're continuing to live in these
limited behaviors and people eat eight
bags of Doritos and this oh my god I've
ate all these Doritos I better have
three apples just stop after the fourth
bag of Doritos right it's funny you said
that because I have a giant bag of
Doritos haha it's on my desk
and it's said yeah this is this is like
the half human size that you buy a
Costco it's yes sir all day long because
all I want to do is eat that thing and
and I have a strategy called damn do
Doritos because I per mind having that
right here next to me all day long
reminds me that I'm stronger than the
Doritos yeah cuz the Doritos you know
it's interesting there was a great
strength coach in Vancouver's name was
Peter twist and and I was at this
underarmor event in Bradenton Florida
and they had Under Armour's kind of top
performance people in this performance
council and in when we we started this
uh this meeting he held up a bag of
Doritos in his right hand and the Apple
in his left hand and he
said do you really need a nutritionist
to tell you which is better for you
alright you know what he said the
question is why should you choose the
Apple and you know I've taken that and
gone everywhere and you think about that
question right it people want to look at
okay I've got to develop these
affirmations I've got I've got to go to
my headspace app for an hour just choose
an apple start there you know and and I
think that that success is in the
simplicity and I love that you do that
but I also would say the easiest thing
for you to do is not have the bag there
you know and and I mean some of the
statistics recently you watched three
minutes of news you increase the
probability by twenty seven percent that
you're you know at the end of the day
you'll say you had a bad day right well
who controls what I watch yeah we're
gonna go into sometimes some work
environments that are tough and that are
challenging but you know as an
entrepreneur I've been doing a lot of
venture capital work here in LA with
upfront venture capital and a bunch of
others and Michael Johnson the Olympic
sprinter and I did an event recently and
I was just looking at some of the
statistics on the Gallup poll I mean
only twenty six percent of Fortune 2000
companies are engaged their employees
are engaged fifty five percent just put
in time 19 percent are actively
disengaged those are tough ratios one
out of four engage them in this similar
sports and then I saw another statistic
in an eight and a half hour workday the
average employee productivity is four
hours and if employees dealing with any
emotional problems financial distress
divorce it might be 1.5 hours out of
eight and half hour day those are unique
challenges for entrepreneurs or for CEOs
managing these ratios what are you doing
to help people help themselves you know
and and I think that that's that's the
number one goal that we we try to do
with the sport programs I've been and
give the players tools they can be
educated derelicts but at least they
have the information to be the best
version of themselves right they see the
easy thing to do would be to get rid of
the bag and not have it here at all I
have it here because it's difficult like
I want to run into difficult I want to
do it
maybe I'm just messed up nothing wrong
with that it's building your
psychological stamina but I'm also
saying that
that in the absence of it right you know
sometimes we put this thing in front of
us you know we can just for example like
television you know just be in a
different room or just not turn it on if
it's on we're gonna probably watch it
and and you know Christine Paula at the
professor Georgetown said that you know
negativity is almost a multiple of four
to seven times more powerful than
positivity and when we say things out
loud they're almost 10 times more
powerful than when you think them Evan
so if you just took that statistic you
know at some level you know what we say
out loud might be 40 to 70 times more
powerful if it's negative right so so
sometimes the things that I don't say
what if I just don't say I don't like
working here now I'm not saying the
alternative
I'm just not externalizing these certain
things and so sometimes I think like you
know having that bag of Doritos or
having that TV on or having you know any
of those different types of things I
think becomes a really unique challenge
for us we're tempting ourselves in a way
that that abstinence would make a little
bit easier for us but I love it I love
it I'm gonna add a bag of Doritos damn
did the reader these three toes are not
stronger than me I mean that's people
asked me doesn't it doesn't it take you
take away your willpower and for me
maybe I'm just weird that builds my
willpower just love no I agree yeah
really
so talking language you talked about a
bunch of times I'm super curious your
opinion so for me if it if the answer to
why I'm not doing something is scary
difficult or hard
that means it's go time like that's not
an acceptable answer that means I have
to do it if the answer is scary
difficult or hard what what are the
language things that people are telling
themselves that prevent them from and it
may be especially out loud if it's ten
times more powerful that is that are
preventing them from having the
constructs that they're after well a
really good friend of mine captain Tom
JD used a former commander of SEAL Team
5 and you know we spent a lot of time
the sports world working with the
Special Operations community in a
partnership around this program called
the tactical athlete program and we
learned a lot about psychological
strength from them they learned a lot
about taking better care of their their
operators you know physically from the
sports world and one of the things that
that he told me I think relates to your
question you know he said the seal
communities to top this concept see
before T and when they're facing
difficult situations you have two ways
to look at it am i being threatened okay
so this scary event this difficult
moment is it threatening me because if I
feel threatened
I physiologically will shut down or am I
being challenged okay because when I'm
challenged when I'm in a difficult
situation like okay all right the odds
are against to run out a little bit
tough I'm being challenged then I
physiologically rise up so they call it
C before T so how do I look at a
difficult situation from the perspective
of this is a unique challenge I've got
to find a way through versus this is a
threat that could really put me in a
really difficult situation financially
or personally and so where I think
language becomes debilitating is when we
constantly talk about the challenge in
terms of man I don't think I can do this
you know what we don't have the same
things they have they have better
players and let's take Russell Wilson
for example okay you know football has
metrics okay and those metrics are real
and so a quarterback ideally is gonna be
about six four and a half and probably
somewhere around 235 okay they're gonna
have anthropo metrics which is their
their arm length or handle length their
legs that they're you know girth with
all that stuff probably more than
anybody who's just listening wants to
listen to but Russell doesn't fit a lot
of those metrics right so he's 510 okay
so physiologically there aren't any
examples like you going to ten million
he didn't have role models right okay so
instead of focusing on what he didn't
have from a young age he focused on
using what he did have and so many
people Evan end up limiting themselves
because of who they think they're not
well I'm not adding look at how many
people he has look I'm not adding look
at all the things that as opposed to
well what do I
so so for us at 5:10 he's got big hands
he's competitive he's willing to get up
at 4:00 in the morning and study
he's got quickness and he's willing to
train and go above and beyond and again
he aggregates the marginal gains how he
sleeps he prepares and he uses what he
has and and I think if we measure
ourselves on the level of effectiveness
we're getting out of our own potential
we would be stunned with how far we go
and if we stop limiting discussions
talking about what we don't have what
our organization doesn't have what our
team doesn't have what my family doesn't
have what my gender doesn't have all
these different things we're not
pretending those things aren't real
we're just taking away their power
neutral thinking is really a language it
says when something bad happens it
happened and that's I think the problem
people have with positivity and I'm
raised my dad was one of the first
authors that Chicken Soup for the Soul
write Evans so I got a seminar every
night at dinner okay but what happens
for sometimes when people are told to be
positive they're in a state that feels
really distant from that so in my mind
it was like a car can't go from reverse
to forward without going to neutral so
how do we downshift and say all right
this just happened and it wasn't good or
this just happened and it was okay but
what I do next not how I feel
determines what happens next and and
that's where I think behavior becomes
more powerful than emotion and so many
of us are regulated by emotion where you
know when I feel like it I'm gonna do it
but but ultimately when you do it
halfway through it you'll feel like it
and that could be as simple as mowing
the lawn you know I I'm as you get out
there mother want man I'm glad I did it
but if you wait around to feel that way
you know you won't I think to go back to
your original question what are the
behaviors that get somebody to 10
million followers forget your industry
you know what what what are those
behaviors and am i living in alignment
with it you know Tiger didn't have any
role models people say oh hi girls has
all these gifts who looked like him
before and who's looked like him since
it's what he did
not what he had loved it Trevor thank
you for the time man really appreciate
your insights I can't wait for the book
it takes what it takes for people who
want to buy the book where they want to
dive deeper into your story where do you
want them to go well it takes what it
takes is a really cool story and I want
to thank Shannon Wells from
HarperCollins she had just finished shoo
dog and unearthed me out of the ashes
and tracked me down which was cool after
Russell Wilson and I did a show called
quarterback to quarterback on ESPN but
it's a HarperCollins you can pre-order
it right now on pretty much every device
that's possible and the foreword is
written by Russell Wilson the Seattle
Seahawks quarterback and really is an
exploration of how we came to this idea
of neutral thinking and behaviors versus
emotion and it gives you some unique
insight into some of the best athletes
competitors and teams in the world and
how those architectures were built and
how that translates to regular life
going back to Maria's goal how are we
affecting more than 150 athletes so I
want to thank Jay Connolly for the
opportunity to do this with you today
Evan and I'm excited to continue to talk
and you know what I also want to say for
people listen to all of Evans channels
because I had a chance last night to go
down that rabbit hole which kept me up
late but there's so much great
information in education and I think
education giving ourselves it's like
giving yourself lottery tickets you know
a thousand lottery tickets doesn't mean
you're gonna win it you can win it with
five but it gives you a better chance so
I think what you're doing Evan is giving
people a better chance to be a better
version of themselves I love it man so
for the YouTube audience we'll link that
up the book it takes what it takes in
the description and Trevor thank you for
for the conversation for the wisdom and
I'm gonna I'm gonna apply it in my life
in business as well you bet thank you so
much Evan okay take care if you want to
see the one on one I did with Tony
Robbins check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there it's not the amount of money it's
the amount of time time is your greatest
friend here